[Musique]
alexis poulain merci est d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors le
projet de loi de finances pas
d'augmentation de taxes sur l'essence
assure bercy pour autant la tentation
reste telle grande
oui à bruno le maire a rassuré tout le
monde dans ce débat sur le projet de loi
de finances 2009 1 en disant qu'il n'y
aura pas bien pas de nouvelle taxe que
le gouvernement restait sur cette ligne
mais la tentation est grande de trouver
des moyens pour trouver des recettes
pour l'état et c'est sûr que tout a
commencé avec cette idée de la taxe sur
les carburants
en revenant avec un centime chaque année
jusqu'en 2022 2023
les taxes sur le carburant on se
rappelle c'est la taxe carbone c'est le
début du mouvement des gilet jaune
pourquoi vouloir à tout prix remettre
sur la table cette idée qu'ils avaient
bien mis dans la rue tous ces français
qui avaient du mal à finir le mois
donc fin de non recevoir le gouvernement
recule mais néanmoins cherche de
nouvelles idées pour taxer les français
et il ya cette idée qui vient de 40
députés de la majorité en marche qui
proposerait une redevance pour tous y
compris ceux qui n'ont pas de poste de
télévision à la maison puisque
aujourd'hui on peut regarder la
télévision sur différents supports
d'écran et donc la télévision n'est plus
le seul objet qui ferait qu' il y aurait
la redevance donc voit bien qu'en termes
d'aventis vite et d'impôts de taxes
nouvelles on peut faire confiance au
gouvernement il va falloir être
extrêmement vigilant pour voir ce qui
est pas de nouvelles taxes qui viennent
se faufiler dans ce projet de loi de
finances sur les jouets on en parlait
taxe plastique taxe sur les transports
aériens taxe sur d'autres carburants
taxe bien sûr augmentation des prix du
gaz de l'électricité à partir de janvier
ou plus tard donc restons vigilants
parce que malgré les promesses
peut-être que le gouvernement va
redoubler d'inventivité pour trouver des
moyens quand même de taxer les français
et de remplir les caisses de l'état
justement quelles sont les pistes qui
pourraient être envisagées par le
gouvernement
alors les pistes envisagées par le
c'est clair on ne touchera pas à l' isf
on ne revient pas sur l'impôt il faut de
la stabilité fiscale notamment pour les
plus riches
même si pourtant beaucoup d'économistes
sont en train de
militer pour que les riches payent leur
part parce que comme vous le disiez dans
le sujet précédent
le confinement à faire entrer dans la
pauvreté plus d'un million de français
qui étaient déjà dans la précarité
donc pas de retour sur cet isf ni sur la
baisse d'impôts de production rien de
tout ça alors peut-être que le
gouvernement attend une taxe européenne
sur les gaffes à qui est le serpent de
mer dont on parlait cet été et qui va
peut être venir une taxe aussi à
l'apport peut-être des mesures
protectionnistes aux frontières
européennes qui pourraient remplir les
caisses de l'état
et puis il ya pourtant des ong qui l ont
des idées c'est greenpeace qui ce matin
proposait une taxe écologique pour les
plus riches pour les plus hauts revenus
parce que c'est eux qui ont un mode de
vie qui polluent le plus et donc proposé
aux plus riches de payer en fonction de
leurs achats de leur transport
parce que c'est eux qui ont la plus
grosse trace carbone et donc pourquoi
pas retrouver les sf mais écologique pas
les sf tout court donc les idées ne
manquent pas mais le gouvernement lui ne
veut pas retourner à taxer les
entreprises ou les plus hauts revenus et
pourtant ce n'est pas il y aura un
besoin
compte tenu de l'extrême pauvreté qui
est galopante suite au confinement et la
crise du coronavirus et la question de
la bête alors oui alors bruno le maire
évidemment on parle de ce plan de
relance de 100 milliards de la dette
puisque la dette est maintenant c'est
totalement laissé libre par ce qu'il
faut à tout prix relancer l'économie la
soutenir faire en sorte que les
faillites ne soit pas trop nombreuses et
donc 2042c la date annoncée par bruno le
maire pour le remboursement total de la
dette qu'ovide si tout va bien ça
voudrait dire que d'ici à 2040 de la
croissance devrait être au rendez vous
il ne devrait pas y avoir de nouvelle
crise financière ou autre
donc autant dire que c'est quand même
parier sur la comète de très très loin
et puis il ya les prévisions de
croissance alors elles sont bonnes
de la part du fmi et d'autres pour la
reprise mais encore une fois très peu de
visibilité sur cette dette est tous les
thuriféraires de la dette que ce soit le
gouverneur de la banque de france
françois villeroy de galhau que ce soit
pierre moscovici que ce soit christine
lagarde à la bce tous sont d'accord il
va falloir la rembourser cette dette
coûte que coûte malgré là encore des
idées novateur de la part d'économistes
qui propose une annulation de la dette
détenue par les banques centrales pour
éviter justement
et bien c'est cette inflation galopante
de la dette et le prix qu'ils en aient à
payer sur le coût de cette dette comparé
au service public parce que aujourd'hui
la question qui se pose c'est à quoi
vont servir ces milliards des plans de
relance si c'est uniquement pour
soutenir une bulle financière
il faudrait penser planification il
faudrait penser soutien aux petites
entreprises soutien aux ménages c'est ce
que fait le japon par exemple ou
l'allemagne en france on a choisi de
soutenir d'abord les entreprises
on verra ensuite et cette dette on la
laisse courir jusqu'en 2042
c'est l'idée de bruno le maire mais là
encore comme je le disais tout dépend du
taux de croissance tout dépend de la
capacité qu'a la france à rembourser
alors la france est un pays qui jusqu'à
présent va bien qui a une bonne note
vis-à-vis des agences de notation et
donc la dette française est un produit
financier qui marche bien sur les
marchés internationaux donc pas trop de
risque de ne pas pouvoir rembourser
cette dette le problème c'est les taux
d'intérêt de cette dette qui même si
aujourd'hui ils sont très bas grâce à
l'action de la bce
grâce à l'euro également pour s envoler
néanmoins parce que on n'arrête pas de
s'endetter parce que rien ne dit que les
taux de croissance vont revenir à ce
qu'ils étaient avant qu vide rapidement
rien ne dit que les nombreuses faillites
ne vont pas impacter également les
banques qui elles aussi pourrait subir
une faillite systémique donc tout repose
sur un bon vouloir beaucoup d'optimisme
en disant que ce plan de relance ses
plans de relance européens cumulé vont
aider à soutenir l'économie vont aider à
éviter un maximum de fake est donc cette
dette
eh bien elle reste de qualité et elle ne
va pas se détériorer sur les marchés
financiers bon ça c'est un pari on verra
dans les années qui viennent
merci beaucoup alexis poulain
éditorialistes c'était notre rubrique
l'édito fois